une crise dans la crise déjà bien occupé
sur le front du coc vite 19 l'union
européenne doit à présent tenter
d'éteindre un début d'incendié sur le
terrain économique
l'étincelle est partie de hongrie son
premier ministre viktor orban a opposé
son veto le 16 novembre à l'un des
mécanismes du plan de relance promu par
bruxelles conséquence les 750 milliards
d'euros prévus pour panser des plaies de
l'économie liée à la pandémie et le
budget pluriannuel de l'union sont
bloqués ce fameux mécanisme prévoyait de
priver de fonds européens les pays de
l'union qui porterait atteinte à l'état
de droit
une clause derrière laquelle se
cacherait un plaidoyer en faveur de
l'immigration selon viktor orban à
bruxelles aujourd'hui il ne considère
que les pays qui accueillent des
migrants comme étant régi par l'état de
droit ceux qui protègent leurs
frontières ne peuvent être reconnus
comme des pays où l'état de droit
prévost une fois cette proposition
adoptée
plus rien ne pourra empêcher que des
parts des fonds communs revenant aux
états membres servent à soutenir
l'immigration et soient utilisés comme
des moyens financiers pour faire du
chantage aux pays qui s'opposent à
l'immigration car depuis 2015 et la
crise migratoire la hongrie se fait
souvent remarquer pour ses prises de
position hostiles à l'accueil des
réfugiés et à leur répartition entre les
pays membres au veto de budapest
s'ajoute celui de varsovie et de lubiana
le premier ministre slovène a d'ailleurs
interpellé charles michel le président
du conseil européen lui indiquant que
seule une instance judiciaire
indépendante pouvait définir ce qu'est
l'état de droit et non une majorité
politique
par la voix de son commissaire à
l'économie paolo gentiloni l'union
européenne tente tant bien que mal de
rassembler ses troupes
laissez-moi conclure en appelant tous
les états membres a montré un sens aigu
des responsabilités envers les citoyens
mais aussi envers l'europe en cette
période cruciale et d'adopter ce plan de
sauvetage
un plan de relance sur lequel les
vingt-sept avaient pourtant accordé
leurs violons en juillet dernier au
terme de 4 jours et 4 nuits d'intenses
négociations
de son côté paris indique que lieu avant
sera sans les pays qui bloque en cas
d'impasse le sujet devrait donc a priori
être à nouveau au menu des discussions
ce jour pour un sommet officiellement
consacré à la crise du communisme
feu